[Music]
what's up guys mpbhd here and it's that
time of year again so for those who
don't know all the smartphones we're
about to see for the second half of this
year you know galaxy note 10 huawei mate
30 pro pixel 4
iphone 11
all the designs for them
are pretty much done behind the scenes
already and one of the most consistent
cycles and press is the dimensionally
accurate dummies that come out for the
iphone case makers to make their cases
for the new iphone so we have hands-on
of these dummies shout out to sonny
dixon and for 2019 we will again have
three new iphones iphone 11 iphone 11
max and iphone 11r i guess we're
technically not 100 sure that's what
their names will be they could stick
with roman numerals
iphone xi
seems like they probably won't do that
so yeah i'll just call it iphone 11. and
so the main major change that we've all
been seeing in these renders for months
now is this new camera bump on the back
this new tile looking
apple watch looking alien eye bug
looking camera bump and i gotta say i
have very mixed feelings about it see on
one hand i love that we're getting a
meaningful upgrade to the camera on the
iphone it looks like that's gonna be the
biggest change to the new iphone and so
triple cameras is the wave you have your
standard your telephoto and your ultra
wide and that's fun that's what we've
been expecting to see for a while and
i'm crossing my fingers that that ultra
wide is just as good of quality in
photos and videos as the other two
imagine ultra wide 4k from an iphone as
a video camera like i love the mini
trend of adding an ultrawide camera to
these flagships and the rumor that the
pixel 4 won't have an ultrawide camera
makes me sad so i'm a fan of the focus
on the camera
pun intended but
i am not a fan
of the way this looks like this rounded
square thing it's gonna look awkward on
the pixel 4. it already looks kind of
awkward on the huawei mate 20 pro but at
least it's smaller and centered which
actually seems to make a pretty good
difference and making it less jarring
and less alien like and clunky
uh but yeah it's gonna look kind of
awkward on this iphone and it's bigger
also not sure if they keep the color of
the phone back in the camera bump or if
they just make it all black i've seen
renders do it both ways this one's by
venia geskin i kinda like it a little
bit less than having it all black right
now apple does all black in the cameras
but either way it just looks kind of
chunky and also still having a camera
bump not making it flush
i've said this before you can make the
phone a little thicker and have no bump
and that would be cool with me i
remember the days of the iphone 5s not
having a camera bump but this still has
a bump i guess i just don't really know
if i buy that this is the best design
for a new iphone 11 that they could come
up with like we know they usually have
the tick tock strategy 6 and 6s look the
same then new design for 7 and 7s and 10
and 10s so i was thinking about this
potential new sort of boxy modern design
like the ipad pro for the iphone 11 and
we even know tons of people are going to
be waiting for this new iphone
but it kind of seems like they just
mailed it in it's just the same design
with the new camera i don't know makes
me wonder when we're going to start to
see iphones not designed by johnny ive
anyway just just stop ranting about the
new design for a second what else can we
expect from these three new iphones well
it's looking like we'll have the same
screen sizes for the iphone 11 and
iphone 11 max you know still 5.8 inch
and 6.5 inch still oled the front-facing
camera suite is also expected to be
similar likely new sensors for improved
and faster face id but still one selfie
camera still a notch
still the same kind of huge notch in the
world where almost everyone is rapidly
getting rid of theirs and then the signs
are strong that they will actually be
getting rid of 3d touch so if you
remember the the pressure sensitive deep
presses and force touches
um to me this is fine this isn't
something i use all the time other than
maybe lock screen flashlight and camera
shortcuts but you can get them with a
long press anyway so i'm not super
bummed about that i just wish it made it
cheaper anyway we should get a new spec
bump of course to the new chips
alongside ios 13. but aside from that
still lightning again still asymmetrical
speakers at the bottom no usb type-c
thanks apple and overall just the rest
of the design is pretty much the same as
the 10 and 10s same shapes same rails
same chamfer
same or very similar colors you know
that's the whole deal and then with the
iphone 11 r it'll be interesting to see
what they do with the display
and the cameras the display just because
that was basically the biggest complaint
a lot of people like me had with this
iphone having a low pixel density and
not the greatest display even though it
turned out to be not a huge deal for
most people and they end up buying it
anyway but you know fingers crossed
maybe they'll improve that a bit and
then of course the iphone 10r had a
single camera in a world of dual cameras
it looks like this iphone 11r is also
going to have one less camera than its
brothers so if you look closely at these
models you'll notice the flash is in a
very different place on the 11r where
the third camera would be and so sure
enough there's only two cameras on that
budget iphone where there's three on the
flagships and i am hoping that means
it's going to be a standard and an ultra
wide
i kind of think apple's going to end up
doing that because you can still do
portrait mode without the telephoto and
they got rid of the telephoto for the
10r so i think the 11r will be standard
and ultra wide
i hope then as far as extras like
reverse wireless charging
can't really tell from the renders i
mean they're still going to have the
glass backs most likely but we don't
know about that so yeah no usb type c
the battery
may be marginally larger a little bit
not hugely no 120 hertz display is
expected anyway fingerprint reader under
the glass also not expected if they
stick with face id like they're supposed
to
just overall a pretty underwhelming
update this really seems like the first
time they're not doing a major design
shift after the s version of the iphone
we go from 10s to 11 and it's looking
very similar usually for these videos
looking at the models we would go super
hard with after effects magic so you
could get a better idea of what it would
look like on a working phone if you're
holding it in your hand
but the differences are so minimal you
almost can't tell it looks just like an
iphone 10 or 10s like just from looking
at this piece what this model is telling
me is the camera is going to be the
biggest upgrade on the new iphone it'll
be interesting to see how they sell that
and they'll probably go super hard about
it on stage to justify
this
but if you're one of those people who's
you know pretty opportune to upgrade
every single year with the new iphone
based on having new features
that is pretty much the only new feature
to look forward to as far as we know but
yeah that's been it i'm kind of curious
would you skip this new iphone i know a
lot of people you break a phone you kind
of need a new phone and you just gotta
wait till september and then this comes
out and you get it but would you skip
this new iphone let me know in the
comments section below i'm curious
either way thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace